this video is sponsored by bespoke post
you know what I think is awesome
receiving top quality items from lesser
known brands in a specially made box
delivered right to my doorstep and guess
what there just so happens to be a
monthly membership called bepoke post
that will do just that for you too every
month members are introduced to all
sorts of cool new products that change
month-to month like outdoor gear kitchen
goods barware and even live oysters
based off of a preference quiz that
you'll fill out and the quiz is actually
pretty accurate I mean I was even given
this beanie turns out I really like it I
received the Switchback box that came
with a solar inflatable light a military
grade Compass a fire starter Stone a
utility knife and a trifold Camp shovel
and speaking of all this outdoor stuff I
also received the very excellently
paired bundled box that came with the
beanie that I'm wearing and a scarf and
even a money clip 90% of the products
come from small Brands many of which are
based right here in the US such as the
knife and the Terra box which is made by
Bare Bones based in Salt Lake City every
one of these boxes of awesome has about
$70 worth of items in it but you'll
never have to pay that much it's like
magic quite frankly and it's free to
join and you always have all of the
power to preview the boxes that are
assigned to you and either swap them out
before they're shipped or skip a month
if you deem it necessary or cancel alt
together at no extra charge so to get
20% off of your first box of awesome
click the link in the description and
enter Bandit 20 at checkout or go to
bespokepost.com
bandit2 and now on to the
video who doesn't like some good old
lore playing a video game is already fun
enough but often times when good old
lore is involved it can serve to deepen
the experience that much more and
sometimes especially with games like
Elden ring lore can get kind of weird at
times which is great because normal is
boring so since we're all sitting around
waiting for the Elden ring DLC at this
point and since it's been a hot minute
since I covered it on the channel let's
kill the time by refreshing our memories
and seeing if you knew just how weird
Elden ring lore can get oh and spoiler
alert obviously start starting with the
most obvious and working to the least
obvious did you know that Margot is
actually morot mindblowing I know how
about there are gods that fight for
control of the lands between known as
the outer gods and the most prevalent of
them is known as the greater will and
the greater Will's Messengers are giant
fingers called the two fingers and
another outer God that works against the
greater will known as the frenzied
Flames similarly has giant finger
Messengers but they're called the three
fingers and featured three fingers and
no there's no reason or explanation for
this finger Obsession from the outer
Gods they're just big fies maybe it's
symbolic of all the meddling the outer
gods do to the lands between patches is
in this game patches is in pretty much
every Souls born game patches in and of
himself is an enigma Queen America is
her second husband conversely King
gragan is his second wife quite
literally we even see them transform in
the same body in front of our eyes boobs
and hair and everything to this day it
is not expressly clear as to how this
happened or or why it happened or if
it's always been a thing with them two
but either way it definitely takes
marriage to a whole new level and
speaking of taking marriage to a whole
new level prer Reichard the child of
rigan and renala committed blasphemy by
allowing himself to be eaten by the god
devouring Serpent and thus merging with
it
becoming this after his very easy defeat
at the hands of the tarnished hero his
consort tanith gets pretty devastated by
his death and decides that she'll bring
him back to life by eating him you know
like the god devouring serpent how
romantic and that's not the end of the
weird marriages in the game the Unholy
Omen stricken child of America and
Godfrey known as Moog fell in love with
his little half brother Mika and
kidnapped him and then forced him to be
his consort and then decided to live
inside his little brother's body in his
veins as his blood # couple goals
everyone knows that Godwin the child of
America and her first husband Godfrey
was assassinated on the night of the
black knives by way of the Rune of death
but did you know that afterwards his
body was taken to the roots of the her
tree where he turned into a giant clamed
merman thing and that's where death
route comes from speaking of children
Elden ring is a great game for adoptive
fathers when Sir Lionel the lionard had
met fia the deathbed companion he
immediately declared himself to be her
father just like that and the same thing
happened with sir Gideon ofir and neph L
who was also adopted just like that this
isn't really important to the narrative
at all but in the words of wise man it
isn't a lot but it's weird that it
happened twice right spreading the love
even further is Necromancer GIS who has
the replicated metallic severed heads of
his wife and two children recreated in
Copper on his flail which is already
weird enough but even weirder their
Spirits dwell within the weapon itself
which implies a lot of things so who
knows maybe those actually are their
heads and he killed them and then dipped
them in Copper isn't that how the saying
goes keep your enemies close and your
family family heads closer everyone
knows about the giant her tree in the
middle of the lands between that gives
grace to the tarnished I mean you can't
even look up in the sky at any point
without seeing its branches but did you
know that there also used to be a great
tree that was just known as the great
tree which had roots that entwined with
the ER tree between the great tree the
ER tree and micholas Hal tree Elden ring
has lots of big trees it's a very tree
Centric game Star Scourge Redan has
mastered gravity magic which can be seen
while fighting against him he mastered
this magic so that but he would never
have to give up riding his tiny sickly
little horse called Leonard that looks
like it could barely hold a fly star
Scourge Redan has no feet they either
rubbed off on the sand while he was
riding around the place or rotted off by
the Scarlet rot that his loving half
sister Millennia infested him with who
is infested with it herself actually
leaving her with only one arm and no
eyes yep she does all of this completely
blind what's your excuse back to Star
Scourge ran though he is called the star
Scourge because he literally holds the
Stars still in orbit in order to hold
back the fate of Ronnie the witch whose
Destiny is dictated by the Stars which
is more badass than weird speaking of
Ronnie though lots of fans really like
her and are quite thrilled about the
notion of starting a new Dynasty beside
her as her consort I'm sure for very
wholesome reasons of course however this
is Ronnie's body this is a doll that
Ronnie's Spirit inhabits something tells
me the relationship will have to be
wholesome Because unless she's another
kind of doll entirely I don't think
she'll be able to do much other than you
know just sit around talking about life
and stuff land octopi are technically
human their babies are made out of human
blood so that right there that that's
that's human DNA at its finest maidens
who strive to be finger maidens of the
three fingers must be blinded and guided
to a distant light that they see in
their eyeless Vision that is enhanced by
ingesting shabiri grap which sounds fine
I mean who doesn't like a grape every
now and then the thing is they're not
actually grapes at all they're eyeballs
and they actually do lead her to the
three fingers so you know if you're
stuck in life just eat an eyeball the
cute little living jars are actually
stuffed with meat not just any meat
though meat from Warrior humans meaning
these jars are the reanimated dead flesh
of Fighters which is why they strive to
be Warriors themselves and they pass on
their family trees by passing on their
innards to smaller jars I don't care
they're still cute though you've heard
of artificial intelligence while in
Elden ring there are artificial humans
called aloric but they're not perfect
humans because their legs deteriorate
pretty quickly and once they deteriorate
all the way they die just like that
however the second generation of alanic
however the second generation of albinar
beings have very dextrous Limbs and in
order to counteract their older lame
versions they cartwheel around the place
just to prove that they can they also
have fro heads last but not least when
ending the game successfully within the
frenzy flame quest line melan turns from
your reliable finger Maiden into your
worst nightmare literally she gets so
mad at you for destroying the world and
most importantly torrent The Goat horse
I mean the gors that her eyes have a
complete Terminator style makeover her
open Golden Eye becomes glazed over and
gray and her closed tattooed eye opens
and is now super bluish purple she also
threatens you with destined death which
is another word for the Rune of death
which famously was used by Ronnie who
also knows
torrent yeah there are lots of theories
there some of which I have made myself
but everything that happens with melon
at the end of the game is definitely
weird interesting but weird so there you
have it folks how many did you know if
you learned something new leave a like
on the video to get it spread around
more on the internet and generate even
more hype for the DLC and if you are
excited for the DLC subscribe to the
channel if you haven't already to stick
around for lots of lore coverage when it
drops and if you still need some
Refreshers feel free to check out my
videos covering the stories of Ronnie
melan America and then some huge thanks
as always for watching the video and to
my Bandit crew for keeping the channel
alive and be sure to comment below
letting me know what part of Elden ring
you think will lead into the DLC that's
all I've got for this one so follow me
on my socials and I'll see you next time
this is Bandit signing out
[Music]
peace